if you ask somebody how you made this
sound or or what equipment do you use
the answer I don't tell you this my
professional SEC but in electronic
community I meet opposite people with
big love share their
[Music]
knowledge flad crimer is a synthesizer
inventor but he's doing things
differently he's always seeking for the
purest form of self-expression and to
him that involves plenty of
noise whole my life devoted to music
from the very beginning firstly as a
collector and then as a sound producer
as a musician and now as a producer of
synthesizers Flat's company Som
laboratory is dedicated to creating
unconventional synthesizers which are
played by music musicians all over the
world the very first memories of my
music is a small real recorder of my
father my father did a lot of recordings
from radio and it was a very uh weird
mixture of different songs different
countries languages for me music is a
magical s that is why I love it so much
so what is a synthesizer well they
emerged in the mid 20th century using
electronic circuit to generate sounds
whilst they went through many iterations
the most popular design has a keyboard
to make them accessible to piano players
users could then sculpt their sound
using filters and effects recreating
acoustic instruments or creating
something entirely
[Music]
new blad developed synthesizers for his
own performances for years but his drone
machine Lyra gained some interest after
he shared a demo on YouTube and with
that s laboratory was
born lra can scream screams like Beast
uh lra can
produce very complex noise he is a very
philosophical and actually heart State
of
Mind The Ether is a handheld device
which flat cause an anti- radio it
detects interference and radiation from
objects all around us it's like a
additional sense there is a very complex
uh electromagnetic World created by
Humanity unconsciously without special
intentions and when I uh discovered it I
was very amazed how complex and Rich it
is apart from these noise machines Vlad
isn't afraid of Melody crafted from
solid wood Terror uses metal sensors to
detect your finger movements and can be
played by anyone even without a musical
background Tera has absolutely different
mode it is a perfect balance between
nature and
Technology like super simple interface
with very complex possibilities s are
prolific and they are constantly
releasing new products fans pre-order
these instruments up to a year in
advance each product is presented with a
bizarre demo video which always grabs
people's
[Music]
attention these instruments aren't just
for Fringe artists in fact their unusual
organic sounding tones lend themselves
perfectly to cinema and game soundtracks
including the soundtrack for cyberpunk
2077 and a classic Horror
Story
I would say that acoustic instruments is
like a very solid person it has very
recognizable face even some expression
of emotions that usually you can see on
this face but synthesizer is chameleon
so it's like a perfect actor that has
multiple faces and even even with a good
synthesizer nobody knows how many fa it
has and this is the biggest power of
synthesizer because it's very flexible
so the the best part of synthesizer is
not even that you can program different
uh Timbers using the same machine but
that you can play Chambers so they can
you can change
Chambers right among your
performance
of course it's very complex process
because I not only need a good
imagination about possible things uh but
I also need very nice connection with
technical possibility so that is why my
work is very hard I need to make a
perfect balance between strong idea and
strong philosophy possibility to make it
in the real world with existing
Technologies and possibility don't make
it very expensive with my imagination
very easy can reach €
100,000 not a problem at all but
unfortunately not too many people will
buy
it most of artists will agree with me it
is a combination of reflection of outer
world this reflection processes your
inner world this is like my reaction of
s that I see around when I propose some
instrument usually it is a philosophical
statement so maybe I even more
philosopher than an
[Music]
engineer
for